right now dr doom and gloom flip-flop
fauci faced a tough line of questioning
from congressman jim jordan yesterday as
fauci
struggled to answer when we would return
to normal
failed to explain why he has been so
wrong
so often that didn't seem to stop maxine
waters from losing her cool
snapping at congressman jordan because i
guess his questions were a little too
tough
on flip-flopping fouchy take a look
you're going to see the level of
infection come down and down
and gradually there will be more
flexibility for doing the things that
you're talking about where does it get
to when it comes down what number do we
get our liberties back tell me the
number
give me the number the members of
congress get vaccinated but you're not a
doctor mr clyburn he is what is the
number
mr chairman mr chairman i don't want you
to answer my question the american
people want dr
fauci to answer the question what does
it have to be fire sir
if you need to respect the chair and
shut your mouth
wow shut your mouth painful all right
now thankfully down in florida ron
desantis has gotten it right from the
start
he didn't surrender to the mistakes of
the so-called experts
he protected the elderly one thing they
got right
this impacted older people much harder
than younger people he protected the
nursing homes
he mobilized every state agency to
protect seniors
he prioritized getting seniors
vaccinated he safely reopened his state
and he respected the dignity of working
people and then you can compare that to
the
nursing home executive order disasters
of cuomo
and murphy and wolf and whitmer yeah
they all got it wrong
and by the way they continue to fail
their citizens every single day
governor desantis is succeeding
everywhere
that they're failing including on the
issue of law and order as the governor
is now expected to soon sign a bill
that's an anti-riot bill that would hold
demonstrators
accountable with stiff penalties if
any violence is committed here to
explain more
is the governor great state of florida
ron desantis
you know i'm an idiot i'll start out
this interview i
should be live you should be my governor
i don't have a governor the governor is
not going to take my call
i don't have a senator in new york i
don't even have a congressman in new
york that will take my call
and now new york city and state
income taxes 15 i live in the second
highest property tax county in the
country
go you can call i'm an idiot i should be
in florida you should be my governor
and sean they're going to take an even
bigger pound of flesh out of you as you
know with the tax increases that are
coming
down the pike there here's an
interesting fact
new york has about 3 million fewer
people than florida
yet new york's budget is twice as much
as florida yet
if you were to come down to florida and
drive yeah more than twice if you drive
on our roads look at the different
services
we have better infrastructure we perform
better in k-12 education so you're
getting taxed to high heavens
but you're not getting anything for all
the profligate spending
okay so this is pretty fascinating
so three million more people in florida
that you spend less they spend twice as
much
in new york they have and i'm speaking
from experience
the absolute worst infrastructure
and some of the worst schools in the
country especially in new york city
and florida schools are better florida
infrastructure is better
how is it possible that there's that
much waste fraud and abuse
and don't you think it's unfair that the
emergency covert
bailout blue state bill now will take
money from
your citizens in florida and give it to
new york state
to the tune of billions of dollars
well it's very unfair because it rewards
them overall for being
more profligate in their spending but
then for this time
because they said if you have low
unemployment like florida does you get
less
if you have high unemployment you get
more so we got less than our per capita
share new york and california are
getting much more
so it's really incentivizing these
lockdowns which is a huge mistake
but you know sean i think that when you
look at all this stuff
you'd mention the annie rioting bill you
know obviously doing the covet having
the open state open school is very
important
but over the summer we were one of the
states that said we're not having riots
in the state
of florida and so we put our foot down
we protected our folks
the bill i'm going to sign very soon is
the strongest set of reforms in the
country
to even strengthen our hand more for
example if a local government tries to
defund the police
we at the state can stop that we're able
to put people in jail
if they riot or assault a police officer
in fact you assault a police officer
during a riot you have a mandatory jail
sentence of at least six months
we also have provisions to prevent mob
intimidation tactics
and i think it's probably the most
comprehensive piece
of law and order legislation i've seen
well it's it's
the anti-riot which by the way in new
york
we have images of all the people that
have been writing and attacking police
officers
we don't use that video to arrest them
and charge them
and by the way if they did do that you
know new york state has
a zero bail bill bank robbers
they go in they get booked and then they
get instantly released
everybody gets released and then they
reoffend and we're doing the exact
opposite sean
if you are rioting and you get arrested
you go to the jail and you stay in jail
until you have your first appearance
and then obviously the judge can
determine whether you get a bond or not
but we're not going to just have someone
go into the police station
take a mug shot and then go right back
on the street to reoffend again
we also have a provision which i think
you'll appreciate because some of these
local governments in these deep blue
areas
they just told the police to stand back
they let some of this happen
in our bill if a local government does
that and they breach their duty to
protect the public
then if you are damaged you can sue the
local government
for damage to yourself or to your
property
is there anything you are planning to
mitigate if the democrats
move forward with h.r 1 sr1
that would protect the constitutional
role of state legislatures
as it relates to the the time the means
and and ways elections occur in a state
well you would immediately see
constitutional challenges mounted from
florida
and other states about the overall
constitutionality of it i think it's
unconstitutional
but even in the most favorable light
clearly
it can't be constitutionally applied to
a presidential election
constitution is very clear the state
legislature not the congress
selects the electors it also can't be
applied to state elections
so governor state legislature state
senator there's no way they can reach
that
so i think it would be a massive mess i
do think the courts would strike it down
but we are we absolutely would not allow
that to apply
uh to a presidential election or to a
state election
you've got to have a certain sense of of
personal satisfaction
considering 60 minutes tried their hit
piece on you
and it blew up in their face
yeah well look sean i mean they came
down for three months all they were
trying to do is smear me
we had a lot of people doing things like
going to my website
rondasanus.com they've been helping out
a lot of people have really gotten our
back on this but the fact is the truth
is the truth
60 minutes lied they tried to smear
fortunately we had the facts on our side
and i have a platform
where i'm able to defend myself you know
sean i look and see how this media
operates as corporate media
what about all the people they've
smeared over the years who are not
governors who don't have a platform to
fight back
they've gotten away with smearing people
for years and years
they came after me and i'm willing to
fight back and so yes it blew up in
their face
and honestly it serves them right for
what they did it was disgraceful
governor thank you sir